[Music]
i'm gonna tell you a story
at first it's gonna sound ridiculous but
the longer i talk
we have to find the keys the more
rational it's going to appear
i can't believe you found coffee sugar
right here
oh three
how many times have we been here
how many times for me it's been an
eternity
[Music]
the invasion will fail we lose
everything
i die within five minutes of landing on
that beach
along with every other soldier
how did you do that come on come find me
when you wake up
you do know what's happening to me what
happened to you happened to me
you hijacked their power how do i
control it you have to die
every day keep coming here and i'll
train you
again again your legs broken
no i'm good then you better start over
oh come on
i'm not a soldier of course you're not
you're a weapon
they want to conquer the rest of the
world
unless you change the outcome we are not
equipped for what's happening
how many times have we been here what
are you not telling me
that's gonna be dark in a few hours and
curl up by the fire and open a bottle of
wine
we should just reset whoa
[Music]
i guarantee you that at some point
everything's going to go south on you
ready
you're gonna say this is it
this is how i end commander mark is dead
now you can either accept that
or you can get to work this will come as
quite a shock to my crewmates
and to nasa and to the entire world
but i'm still alive
surprise here's the rub
it's going to be four years for another
mission to reach me
and i'm in a half designed the last 31
days
so i got to make water and grow food on
a planet where nothing grows
but if i can't figure out a way to make
contact with nasa and none of this
matters anyway
you've got an incoming message my
okay so let's do the math i have enough
food to last for 50 days
he's going to starve to death long
before we can help
so i'm going to have to science the [ __ ]
out of this
he's 50 million miles away from home
he's totally alone the hell is he
thinking right now
i am the greatest botanist on this
planet
i know how to save mark watney but we
need the hermes crew we either have a
high chance of killing one or a lower
chance of killing six
i'm not risking their lives it's bigger
than one person
no myself
[Music]
nasa rejected the mission so if we do
this we're talking
mutiny if anything goes wrong we die
do you realize how crazy this is we had
no other option
no matter what happens
tell the world
tell my family and i never stop
fighting to make it home
good morning today we are talking about
romance languages
any news you want to share there's still
no signs of first contact the objects
measure at least
1500 feet tall dr banks
i'm colonel gt webber i have something i
need you to translate for me
is that not everyone is able to process
experiences like this
last time you did something stressful
does now count
we need answers as soon as possible what
do they want
where are they from
yeah that just happened what happens now
how many we're one of 12. we're a world
with no single leader
it's impossible to deal with just one of
us we need to go back in
i guess i don't need to tell you you put
yourself at risk
now that's a proper introduction to
everything that happens
it comes down to the two of us
i know what it is what does this say
offer weapon
i don't need an interpreter to know what
this means we don't know
if they understand the difference
between a weapon and a tool
china just threatened to destroy their
shell whatever they do
france and korea will follow we could be
facing global war
we need to talk to the other side and
work together for once
we have 15 hours before this all goes to
hell
i know why they're here what the hell is
she doing
do trust me
what are you going to do with it i'm
going to give it something socially
responsible to do
can't we just let it go this thing needs
to learn how to adapt
our game let's mask up like the rest of
[Music]
us
this world's a treasure there's been
times to leave for a while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last to survive on earth
you're the best pilot we ever had get
out there
and save the world everybody ready to
say goodbye to our
solar system to our galaxy
here we go
we're here
[Music]
i want to get down fast don't we
actually we want to get there in one
piece
hang on
[Music]
we have a mission our mission does not
work if the people on earth are dead by
the time we pull it off
[Music]
we got this far rather than any human in
history well not far enough
[Music]
make it count where's the mountains
those are mountains
the waves
yes you are yes you are
you might have to decide between seeing
your children again
and the future of the human race
we'll find a way who we always have
[Music]
i thought you might be able to help me
with a case
[Music]
any idea where i could find new police
plan on taking me here
i would much prefer that the alternative
every leap of civilization
was built off the back of slaves
replicants are the future but i can only
make so many
i had the luck and he has the key
i think you found him that's not
possible
if this gets out we've bought ourselves
a war
[Music]
your cop did your job once
were simpler than what do you want
i want to ask you some questions what
happened
i covered my tracks scramble the records
we were being hunted
[Music]
by who
i know you're here
you do not know what pain is yet
you will learn bring it to me
[Music]
this breaks the world
we have to go i'm coming with you
where is it
the future of the species is finally
unearthed
who are you
i'm no one
i was raised to do one thing
but i've got nothing to fight for
nothing will stand in our way
i will finish
[Music]
what you started
there are stories about what happened
it's true
all of it
[Music]
the dark side
[Music]
a jedi
[Music]
they're real
[Music]
the force it's calling to you
just let it in
[Music]
[Music]
there's one thing you should know about
me i specialize in a very specific type
of security
subconscious security you're talking
about dreams
[Music]
mr carl has a job offer he would like to
discuss with you
look placement
not exactly we create the world of the
dream
we bring the subject into that dream and
they fill it with their secrets
then you break in and steal it well it's
not
strictly speaking leaving
it's called inception
already
i think i found the way home and this
last job that's how i get there
dreams feel real while we're in them
it's only when we wake up that we
realize something was actually strange
[Music]
this is your responsibility we are not
prepared
dreams collapsing
i have it under control
i need to see out of control
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
a king has his reign
and then he dies
it's inevitable
these are ancient civilizations that
were separated by centuries and yet
this same pictogram was discovered at
every one of them
they're smiling i think they want us to
come and find them
we're all here because of a map you two
kids found in a cave
not a map an invitation from whom
please tell me you can read that
prometheus are you seeing this
whatever that probe is picking up it's
reading live form
what do you mean a life form oh the head
people changing
changing into what
these things moving what is that
there's a ship they're leaving
to go where yes we were so wrong
take us home
big things have small beginnings
explore has been hit explored
i can't see you
lost visual of anymore stone do you copy
yes yes yes i'm detached
i don't know i don't know i'm spinning i
can't i can't
gps is down it's down i can't
give me a visual i told you nothing i
see nothing you have a visual of
explorer no you have a visual of iss
you need to focus
so huh home after stone lake zurich
illinois is there somebody down there
looking out thinking about you
i had a daughter
little girl with brown hair tell her
that i'm not quitting
[Music]
striking news the whole world is
watching the course of human history has
changed today
the ship appears to be stopping over
johannesburg city
they're spending so much money to keep
them here when they could be spending it
on other things
at least they're keeping them separate
from us
[Music]
how do your weapons work
we're coming to you from the entrance of
district 9 the refugee camp set up to
separate aliens
from the general population they told me
i was going to get a vest don't worry
about the vest it'll be fine
in the new agents open the door please
this is an amazing flight i haven't seen
this type of setup
i don't know this has got the markings
there of uh so it's it's definitely
alien
but uh it's uh it's not a weapon
[Music]
we're seeing heavily armed forces being
deployed into district nine
nobody really knew what this place was
[Music]
find the freak
it's gonna be quick it's going to be
clean
first of all it's going to be quiet
there's a lot of secrets in district 9.
many homes have the pretence of being
ideal
but these homes really are ideal
it's not exactly what we're looking for
[Music]
wait no no i don't think this is the
right way yeah this is the way we came
in
no is it did we just do some kind of
loop
hello
i've never heard such silence
what if they don't come
what are we supposed to do
this house is forever the perfect
environment for a young family
people like to be alone sometimes not be
with each other
all the time
[Music]
this is something i could do please just
let me do this
i want to go
that's nature that's just the way things
are
[Music]
good morning theodore good morning you
have a meeting in five minutes
you want to try getting out of bed get
up
you're too funny
[Music]
theodore i saw in your emails that you'd
gone through a breakup recently
you're kind of nosy am i you'll get used
to it
[Music]
what was it like being married there's
something that feels so good about
sharing your life with somebody
how do you share your life with somebody
[Music]
the woman that i've been seeing samantha
she's an operating system
you're dating a west what is that like
i feel really close to her like when i
talk to her i feel like she's with me
i want to learn everything about
everything i want to discover myself
i want that for you too keep going keep
going
falling in love it's kind of like a form
of socially acceptable insanity
[Music]
you're dating your computer she's not
just a computer
you always wanted to have a wife without
the challenges of actually dealing with
anything real and glad that you found
someone
[Music]
i don't know what i want ever
am i in this because i'm strong enough
for a real relationship is it not a real
relationship
[Music]
i can feel the fear that you carry
around
i wish they could help you let go of it
because i don't think you'd feel so
alone anymore
you're beautiful
we're only here briefly and while i'm
here i
want to allow myself joy
i've never loved everyone the way i love
you
me too now we know how
[Music]
he's a smart one is he
what are you gonna name
[Music]
do they look like just apes to you
he saved our lives he was remarkable
i'm safe together
you're him you're caesar
we've been searching for you for so long
i did not
start this war i fight only
to protect apes human
gets sick eat get smart
then human kill it but not me
there are times when it is necessary to
abandon
our humanity to save humanity
they must pay i'll finish this
i offered you peace i showed you mercy
you talk about mercy no matter what you
say eventually you'd replace us
that's the law of nature so look what
you've done
what did the humans promise you
no matter what you don't
have you come to save your apes
[Music]
you